as a start-up it can be challenging to
set your marketing goals you don't want
to waste your time on things that you'll
do nothing with later this is why
setting your goals is so important
consider this please tell me which way
to go from here that depends a good deal
and where you want to go I don't care
much where then it doesn't much matter
which way to go
you're sure enough to get somewhere if
only you walk long enough you need the
goals that are realistic and attainable
it's fine to spend a few minutes
thinking about your vision and
high-level goals like to be the most
visible brand in the industry or make
sure every potential user wants to talk
about our app but as a start-up you
probably don't have enough time to spend
full weeks on wording your high-level
goals you don't want to jump into your
actionable objectives I want you to take
this opportunity to quickly draft to
actionable marketing goals for your own
app idea there is no right or wrong
answer here but we still encourage you
to try it if you don't have your own app
help Lauren and me by drafting two
actionable marketing goals for a
bargmans